oh my god i can't believe this just
happened ma bear look
look at my shirt
yeah what about it you see that whole
line yeah
i straight up drooled on
myself don't you dare [ __ ] hide your
lips for me
don't you dare
i don't know how maybe i'm going into
the senile age but you see that what the
hell look at this
what is this
i was just walking and i opened my mouth
and [ __ ] drool just came out i tell
you how to open your mouth oh my god hey
how about you you clean out your face
how about that how about you smooth it
out got em
hey maybelline called and they want your
foundation back
that came up
so i was just talking to her and i was
like you know what jokes are [ __ ]
lame and you hear the movies all the
time like
they're like they're like the 70s called
and they want their jacket back and i'm
like
is that supposed to be a diss that's the
wackest disc i've ever heard in my life
what did you say no one uses that
anymore
i
know
i know but even back in the day though
even back in the day in the 80s when
people were like oh burn i'm like no it
doesn't burn that's the weakest joke
i've ever heard
well back in the day fourth of july
called and they want their pants back
i burned you
i burned your ass
alright let's go
hey honey and beach called and they said
they want their shoes back
burn
i burnt you
hey pimp my right called
and said they want their car back
burned
burn
all right guys
you guys see
that house back there
it's our new huh it's our new
i'm kidding i'm kidding no i'm just
kidding no actually
um there has been more of our friends
that have been leaning over to this side
and since everyone's super busy but
we're here we're actually checking out
some homes for some of our friends
in case they want to move so we're going
to take you guys on a home tour of
people that are roughly in our age range
our family like people that i have kids
are about to have kids and we'll see uh
if anything what ranges are these houses
uh like million dollar ranges oh the
price yeah i think goes anywhere from
like 600 to about a million so there you
go if you're on the market for anything
600 to a million range
we're introducing you to we should just
become realtors at this point i know
right we should move to vegas and become
real estate agents yeah so here we go
here we go dude
okay so this is the first floor plan
a garage door car garage got dining room
with big old wine cellar thing
office and this is cool because you have
your little wet bar
oh what
damn it's like a hotel
oh yeah nice
that's pretty nice
okay
okay pretty nice
damn
look at that
oh i like that i like that circle hey
little thing
this place feels like a hotel room
and you got a nice little pool all in
that view though
that view that casino view
zam's walk
oh man you made it if you live in here
look at that
nice
stairs bam on fire
i just saw some crazy ass room you ready
okay
whoa whoa
it's a gym gym up in here look at this
microphone yeah you got to microwave a
hot towel so you can put on your face
yeah yeah damn look at this a straight
jam jam
what's in the house
oh i love floor on the ceiling
oh my god look at this
damn
oh you go straight out here you can work
out and jump straight into the pool
lockers for the homies
damn that's tight
what
what i know this is great i'm a bathroom
it's a pilates machine oh i like those
lights underneath there i know it is
really pretty exams walk
how do you feel about these concrete
walls i like it i like these kind of
things
it's pretty cool this is a cool touch
what just
this being able to see oh yeah it's kind
of like our house what's up homie
oh this is the second living room
that's cozy
that's very cozy
oh it's very quiet in here
damn dog
that was really nice man nobody [ __ ]
around with the model homes
it smells kind of funky but yeah it does
damn
but this is cool like this configuration
that's cute yeah
oh my god it's wallpaper it's cute
little tiger room
got some taco room vibes in here yeah
yeah
taika middle school vibes yeah
yeah
what is it
oh it's locked no no it's locked right
here you just got to move it
there you go like that
yep
okay you don't agree with that please
oh great
i hear a water feature out here
down there oh yeah
damn this cool looks pretty deep like a
six footer
oh this is for kids are going to jump in
here that's for sure look at that oh my
god
from here
what's the feature you wanted to see
this oh it's like a nice balcony well
it's big when do you see it this way
yeah that's true you can hang out up
here where are you that's true
how many have you seen like this that's
true i haven't seen that many
and you get to see the casinos that's
that's dope
[Applause]
hey babe look at this
this is a straight-up hotel room
look at this this is really pretty look
at that
you got a straight up wow
bar up in here
wow
this is really
cool they what
damn son
what
whoa
whoa
bro
damn
they ain't messing around
they ain't messing around dude
holy but jesus they ain't messing around
up in here
wow
incredible
all right so this one's nice still has
three car garage
we got what
that's a girly bedroom
so this is an option where you can have
like a guest suite yeah with like almost
like a casita type or um two bedrooms
that's good for the families
because we all got families that i need
to visit wow this is so pretty
oh i love wood
what a statement oh this is really this
is like wow this is a casita yeah we're
in heaven
if only your stupid-ass mama move in
should have our own little space right
here
look at this you can kick it right here
yeah you ma
been wanting you to move here forever
that is nice i feel like a giant
this is really nice
wow
that's dope
okay yeah this is really nice it's like
this big
so basically if you don't choose to have
this area this would be this casita this
will be another bedroom oh okay an
option to have two bedrooms i see
this would be a wall this is nice to
like the guest i like we've been having
guests come over and it's really cool to
have like guests have like their own
space so our friends will probably like
that for their house yeah yeah because
especially
because all of us that's true because
all of our friends have uh diarrhea
problems
and so being able to [ __ ] like without
people listening is pretty good
i'll understand if you never want to
come over to it
it's a weird bet did you like turn it
yeah it sounds like a devil but they
just turned it this way how cute that's
cute
i like the animals on their wall
this is a very cutesy like instagrammy
influencery type of vibe in here
like a as they call the wanderlust or
something like i'm i'm searching for my
soul
i don't know where it went
ooh
yeah that's nice too i'm trying to make
it work here with the little sinks but
it's cute they made it work or two kids
yeah or two people that aren't big like
you
why are you dissing everyone right now
what are you talking about
what do you think about this glass
office
it's cool it's beautiful
so this will be open
this is obviously an option
it's nice it's real nice
that could work
see what's popping
how's the craftsmanship
promise
how's the craftsmanship
this is pretty good
you really couldn't hear me no of course
i can
don't be tricking me
yeah of course i can hear you
yeah
all right going into
the master
oh you know me and rox oh
you're sold
like that masonry
it's pretty cool this master is kind of
small
it's cozy though is it the master
yes it looks like
i mean it's cozy
huh
it is right because of the bathroom
oh wow this is a big uh closet though
whoa
oh no oh never mind yeah i mean still it
looks big it's still big though
this is nice of ours like but like half
yeah yeah
but we got
the dukes
the showers
still good size
really good size actually
oh the view's nice out there damn
got that baller view
lose all my money
you're so weird what are you talking
about
okay let's go go to the living room
that's pretty nice
got a kitchen how cute
countered this is a microwave yeah huge
pantry
oh yeah oh cool you can put appliances
in here and stuff
where right there coffee maker
oh yeah here here hello like blenders
all that kind of stuff super cool i like
this
then we got dining room it's cozy
that fridge looks miniature compare
compared to you yeah
these doors open
oh that's nice
oh i do like the backyard though
oh man
oh they don't have a pool in this one
there's no pool are you kidding me
you need to have a pool dude
but that view though
come on in
well we're learning oh it's pretty nice
right yeah it's like open big and open
i like it you got an office
oh they got the light fixtures i like
they do this is ready for you they got
the floor on the walls and stuff that
you like
a closet i mean this is underneath the
stairs
oh what oh yeah
wait where are you going
it keeps on going oh what yeah tiger's
room yeah tucker's playroom
that's cool
okay
come through here
we got a dining room
that's nice
damn
those are crazy tiles
that makes me feel uncomfortable in what
way like you're locked in a dungeon or
like bug eggs or something you you're
disgusting
this is nice
yeah i like the formal dining right here
i know we'll never use it maybe a couple
times a year when we open all of our
packages
oh yeah
oh it's a nice kitchen
with the nunchuck lights
it's tight
you're so asian what
talking about
palm tree
oh it's a kiss of q he's so cute
okay came up from upstairs
came up through here
got a cool laundry room upstairs
you saw you saw it already yeah what
does it look like something crazy
if they're tigers it could be tight this
room
damn just straight solid slabs that's
dope
like it's not tile
like there's just solid oh got it
oh yeah
this is cool i like this little bench
the injection
nice
okay
you have your gloss wow go do your
homework nice little computer bar
that's pretty cool a little den upstairs
oh you take a picture of this yesterday
at first i thought it was your house oh
no
oh that's cute okay whoa this is a big
room
big monster
i like this couch or whatever this thing
is whoa
holy jesus
damn
wow
[Music]
damn that's nice nice jog
nice
whoa
manga
oh it's another one on this side
yeah his and hers
all right in another neighborhood now
one thing i do really enjoy about this
area
is this clear view to that big old
mountain
so beautiful
i really like that like this whole area
where you have that big mountain on that
side the casino on that side i really
enjoy it like you feel like you're in
nature like you have like a mountain
home but then you get to see the city
that's really cool
all right so the house we're about to go
into
is 2 400 square feet
for
750 000
which is
almost impossible to find in l.a oh yeah
which is why a lot of people are moving
yeah i got a three-car garage
and it's one story
so it's super convenient oh cool we got
a little private courtyard
that's oh it feels serene in here serene
huh that's a big word serene yeah okay
walk in here oh this is nice
oh it feels peaceful and cuny yeah it
does oh it's nice look at that it is
very nice it feels cool this is the
correct size house that we should have
because we only got three pieces for the
amount of people we have yeah this is
dope i like it
i'm not a fan of the brands but we could
always change the colors i mean 700 000
true
that's true
i think this would be like 2 million in
l.a to be honest
i got a nice pool back there
you know i'm saying look at this
oh yeah
i'm familiar because that's usually my
forehead piece this is nice and you got
a little look you see a little pull
actually yeah they did a great um i like
the layout
yeah
damn
yeah i think i like these way better
than the first round in the first round
for our friends yeah yeah i think
they'll like it because these ones are
like it's cool it's like it's a little
bit low but then it goes up so it's a
lot of personality
let's go back there these are the ones
that we can open
disaster
i love this wall texture what is this
called what is it what is it
oh yeah i like that that's what it's
called yeah i like that
yeah that's an upgrade
this feels like um our house
but like
not as exaggerated as that house
this is cool oh this is cool
we do need two shower heads
and we need to install one at our house
somehow if we can
nice closet
nice
all right so we're back in the living
room right here so we ended through here
and if you make a right then you have a
little oh cool office
and then if you go this way
what do you have
a jack and jill
oh bedroom bedroom we've got a bedroom
here you have a bedroom another bedroom
here another bedroom
it's very cool
pretty cool but it's me like jack
fighting with you
oh yeah there's only one sink yeah
so this is a three bedroom but you have
an option to make it for oh because the
office yeah so you can make this
that's pretty cool i feel like so many
people work from home these days though
having an office is very useful i'm sure
this is why they highlight this yeah
what's that garage
oh laundry
laundry
yep
the garage
space like linens linens and blankets
yeah this is
all right check this out you don't see
this in california very often
boom shakalaka boom
four car garage
i think people are realizing they spend
a lot of time at home now
because even for us throwing a home gym
in one of them and having all that
camping equipment we don't really park
our cars in the garage that much so
now you have this and people are
starting to have more multi-generational
living like you know your in-laws your
mom and paw are moving in i don't even
know why i said it like that but your
mom and pop are moving in so it's
helpful to be able to park more cars i
love
these courtyards
like before you get out there it's like
all nice and quiet so cool oh i like
this door
like our door
damn this is crazy
all these second story homes have this
more open floor plan now it's pretty
cool
that's nice
okay
okay
okay
laptop i know it's pretend but oh it's
not even like the last oh cool just the
prop
that's cool
got a little office garage right here
oh yeah oh dang it all that stuff
cool
and then you have another car oh it's
cool you just go out here too
especially if you're a cigarette smoker
take a break
smoke outside even though none of us
smoke
yeah we have an entrance to the two car
garage on that side nice
[Music]
yeah i think i like their ones
the ones that are from this builder they
look cooler huh yeah
but i mean it's up to our friends right
yep whatever they like i'm just
throwing in my two cents
this is cool up here
i love the visibility that they're doing
now from the second to first floor i
just said that
yeah we're noticing the same things
look at that
hello
oh cool those like
vegas or southwest
um
hot spots
yeah oh that's zebra canyon right there
oh yeah
i like that
this looks like red rock
so this one's pretty cool
we're just a little half courtyard in
the front so you get to hang out and
people watch
if people are into people watching you
check out this floor plan
i always love this we can like look up
into the sky but get a little bit of
shade
you walk in oh nice
this is nice i like this one
i think the ceilings are just higher
already
yeah
yeah this one feels good this one feels
artsy and it's really cool
i like this one look at this
yeah
that's dope
yeah you walk in
you got a cool little hangout spot and i
like this builder because look at that
it's it's like diagonal so it kind of
gives things a different feel
instead of like that cookie cutter home
fill you know i mean like they kind of
give it a little bit of pizzazz like
that roof
like that
okay let's go
so here's the
living room
go this way i want to see the garage
door yeah me too is it locked though
no no i'm just kidding
the laundry room goes into your master
class
what they have home dry cleaners
what in the world i didn't know they
could do that
do your own suits at home it's crazy
so this is cool that's the garage you
come home if you got dirty stuff
snowboarding whatever bam pop it in here
go straight into the closet
this is a cool floor plan
i feel like you're batman you know what
i mean like you parked your batmobile
and then you take off your batman suit
and then you come here and then you go
where the ladies at what ladies
we're the la the lady
uh there's only one me
and then you come in here you got the
charlie brown shower
it's pretty cool
and you got double sinks
and then what
weaver's doing oh that's their bathroom
see them yeah and then coming through
here
oh this is cool what is that
oh you see outside yeah i love
covered what are they called logias
lugias
wheels no this is like perfect nice
this is a great size for any any
starting family where it's just like two
three four people
yeah it's cozy it's perfect i think our
friends will love this one
all right this is nice i like seeing
cute courtyards in the front
like a little cute hangout spot when
it's nice and cool
right especially when it's nice and cool
oh you look at the mountains
blue door
this is three to four bedrooms okay
oh nice
still opens up
got the little
little office or den action look at this
thing yeah so this is nice so fun
oh yeah this is great for guests
nice and look it has oh i guess you
could put a door here oh here
oh that's an upgrade or something so
they have their own entrance that'd be
cool that's pretty cool
come here
got a little den
and office action
and then over here we got
whoa
oh another
oh
yeah
come over here got a shared bathroom
love the brass touches
going here and then we got wait there's
a bedroom
oh it's there
from the speakers yeah yeah that was
something
hey look at this
i like how close this outdoor hangout
spot is to the kitchen like the way they
made the shape it feels like you're just
one and the same you know what i mean
espresso
what
oh man it's dope look at how cool the
is really cool
oh
oven
which i like
then the rest of the house doesn't get
really hot yeah i like cooking over here
too see what's going on outside
oh you don't have to worry about cooking
what i always cook we're talking about
so this one you're saying is going to be
a level lower or this that one is a
level lower
so those kings canyons and the palms are
going to be lower got it a lower
community
this is this yes
and then that's the mountains
beautiful mountains look at this it's
like this retro 70s you remember that
this inside i had this on my fireplace
and i hated it as a kid
i know that's crazy well this is a big
courtyard
look how big this one is
whoa
that's kind of cool people hanging out
out here
you know what we could do out here
look you could put string lights you
know how they put like those nice like
those like warm string lights
let's see what's going on here
oh wow that's big in here
wow this is big in here
got a cool
cool living room action
oh i'm not a big fan of these double
counters me neither they probably change
it right
i'm sure
i don't know
yeah
oh that might be a deal breaker oh cut
it out
you know what i like about this room it
feels very like frank sinatra like you
know i mean uh like that
mid-century the med-man madden no not
mad men that's a beach
madman era madmen yeah yeah but very
like mid-century modern it is very
important
i love it it feels awesome in here
all right so this is the master
hey big uni
this is nice
yeah it's a cool slanted ceiling
oh you can and the master can go
straight outside that's pretty
i cool probably build an outdoor shower
right there so i could shout outside too
or you can just walk right into it no no
when you come out of the pool oh i see
it's gonna come through here
and then we got the
bathrooms
oh
that was nice oh i like light i like all
that light actually yeah
nice
too much oh
this is a christina closet for sure
there's like mtv cribs up in here yes
damn my clothes are not this fancy my
clothes are just i would have to buy
brand new clothes it's all barber gate
stuff
imagine just barber game t-shirts i
really kind of take my [ __ ] up and i'm
like no let's throw it all away
so it fits in here what is this
look at this the the pole that you hang
clothes on is the light that's sick
that's so sick
man
technology
i know we're so oh the shelves got
lights too
oh
yeah i love it when everything looks
like a store you know what i mean
yeah
that's dope
cool the first garage we could finally
go into for some reason a lot of these
model homes you can't go in the garage
you lock it but go in this one
that's cool this is one
one space and then some storage
oh to put like workbench stuff that's
tight
nice
imagine this was the gym you got extra
space you could make all this oh jiu
jitsu bats
see this would be the gym right here and
then fujitsu mess
i think we should move too i know i
think we should
yeah
we should tell our friends
they ran out of homes
and then we move
just picked up this duty duty from
school
and we ate yummy dinner and now it's
time for ice cream one for you
and one for me haagen-dazs vanilla milk
chocolate almond it's
delicious
you know how to open it
yeah you want me to help you or no yeah
you do
yeah okay
so now that i'm home with the young buck
i'm gonna spend some time with him
because uh i checked out a bunch of
houses today
and
even when it's just for fun
it's still a lot to take in you know
because i'm trying to like compile notes
of what our friends like oh yeah they
said they wanted a home office
because they have to do this or they
have this kid they want to do that or
they want to run a warehouse out of the
garage so they need a three-car garage
like we're just trying to take notes and
record like actual videos that we're
going to send them on our phone like
right here we just want to bring you
guys through the process because i know
there's a ton of people that are looking
for
other states to move to you know
especially through the last two years
people been meeting on zoom
so they realize like there's so many
companies that don't require you to live
in the city that they're in anymore so
companies are hiring remote like i have
buddies that have companies in la and
they're hiring people from nashville
from canada from india wherever so you
technically don't even have to live
where you work
and
it goes both ways it goes with companies
can hire you from somewhere else and you
can live wherever you want and i think
because of that
people are like well if i live in a
crazy expensive city like san francisco
or new york or la why would i want to do
that if i can move to another place and
get a bunch of brand new homes right and
then on top of that i think with the
onset of the metaverse where people are
really really going to start meeting
online and working and even socializing
online that's going to be zoom on
steroids so i think even more so people
are going to be moving to vegas texas
arizona utah florida just other places
where it has been traditionally cheaper
and you get a lot of bang for the buck
and it's still developing
so i'm happy that since i got my feet
here i can share that with all of you
guys and i know a lot of you guys are in
that next phase of life where you're
looking to either rent or maybe settle
down or see where you can you know build
your life and your family and i hope
that was helpful and
with that i will be spending some time
with our family and i'll see you guys
tomorrow good night